aujourd'hui mercredi sortie sur les
grands écrans de france et de navarre du
film harcèlement avec michael douglas
est démis moore comme son nom l'indiqué
ce film très du harcèlement sexuel mais
aussi et surtout de la lutte pour le
pouvoir dans l'univers impitoyable des
yuppies pascal deschamps un titre une
scène une affiche et je vous imagine
déjà ce matin dans les rues intrigué les
esprits qui s'échauffent la curiosité en
éveil
mais attention harcèlement ce n'est
peut-être pas ce que vous croyez
ce n'est pas un documentaire sur le
harcèlement sexuel
c'est un divertissement mais bien sûr
les gens chargés de promouvoir le film
d'en faire la publicité essaye de mettre
l'image la plus provocatrice pour le
vendre ajoutons à cela que le titre
américain disclosure signifie
révélations en découvertes et vous
comprendrez qu'il ne faudrait pas
réduire le propos du film à une photo
affriolantes collées sur les murs le
film de barry levinson joue en fait sur
deux tableaux d'un côté le fait de
société la guerre des sexes mais avec
inversion des rôles
j'aimerais savoir ce que tu dirais si
c'était toi que c'est arrivé
tu veux savoir combien de fois ça m'est
arrivé qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement la même occasion tu es
tellement artistique
rien n'arrive jamais tant que ça ne
s'est pas d'arriver enfin se font
toujours tom je m'arrange je n'en fais
pas une affaire d'état alors demain
vas-y et trouve une solution
oui je crois que tu as raison que je
devrais me taire et la bdc ça de l'autre
le suspense avec la manipulation que
michael douglas devra déjouer au terme
d'une bagarre par image virtuelle
interposés l'autre scènes fortes du film
est bien me croirez-vous ce qui a fait
causer dans les chaumières
c'est le fait qu'une femme soit capable
de toutes ces horreurs les féministes
m'ont attaqué au moins personnellement
en disant que les trois films dans
lesquels j'ai joué basic instinct
liaison fatale et harcèlement donne une
mauvaise image des femmes
je ne comprends vraiment pas bien sûr
les adversaires les ennemis dans ses
films sont des femmes
et après pourquoi faudrait-il toujours
que ce soit des hommes
bon c'est vrai harcèlement n'est pas à
proprement parler un film politiquement
correct mais combien d'hommes en
sortiront-ils en se demandant et si ça
m'arrivait qu'est ce que je ferai